Holloway when you've done all right
suppose you can actually hold the line
okay
okay well thank you everybody for coming
if you hadn't noticed c-span bookkeeping
is going to be here recording tonight
so during the Q&A portion I will be
passing this microphone around so we can
make sure we get that captured along
with the rest of the talk we are booked
culture is so pleased at a host this
laughs of tonight and conversation with
Terry McDonald the new book the age of
folly out by verso Press and Terry
McDonald's new book also the accidental
life and editors notes on writing and
writers we have plenty of copies up
front and we encourage you to pick up
one or two or three and so we can
continue to be a community space here in
the Upper West Side a quick show of
hands if you've been here before
okay well welcome all of the new faces
twenty years ago this was the Endicott
booksellers but was lost to the Upper
West Side with many other wonderful
independent bookstores over the years
but a couple years ago book culture and
partnership with Harper's Magazine
opened up this space in order to
celebrate the important written word and
them might not always get the attention
it deserves and something that we think
an independent bookstore can offer more
than anyone else and again we're really
happy to be here to be able to bring
great authors in for a great
conversation and Lewis Lapham is the
founding editor of Lapham's quarterly
and in her mayors of Harper's Magazine
his columns received the National
Magazine Award in 1995 for accelerator
for exhibiting an accelerating point of
view in an age of conformity and in 2002
the Thomas Paine Journalism Award he was
inducted into the American Society of
magazine editors Hall of Fame in 2007
and his other books include money in
class in America fortunes child
Imperial masquerade among other titles
carrying McDonnell has won numerous
awards for his editorial work at various
magazines and websites he's also a
novelist and a poet has written and
produced for film and television
painting 2012 he was inducted to the
American Society of magazine editors all
same he's a president of the board of
the Paris Review Foundation and serves
on the Board of Overseers
of the Columbia Journalism Review so
thank you everybody for coming and I'll
go ahead and turn it over to my office
enjoy I believe he turned it over to me
was what let me let me start by giving
you a little background on my
relationship with Louis the just silly
you know you'll know Louis is the has
been for my entire working life the role
model DC it should our typical heroic
figure for all freewheeling editors and
all careful writers is a true thing he
we grew up in the same place really
except his his father was the mayor and
his grandfather had founded Standard Oil
and I was picking apricots down in the
valley but enough about me I just
specifically what what was so important
to me and to almost everyone that I have
ever worked with as an editor is the the
the revolutionary thinking that Louis
did about what that meant and what his
magazines were like we went to school on
them at Harper's when he invented all
the index that was a way to tell a story
that had never been used before
statistical data put ironically into a
particular order that told you more
about your moment in the
three then all the twenty thousand word
pieces that we were trying to bring in
and then there were the readings etc
anyway this is just was so important I
can't tell you and and we follow him
still through you know Lapham squirt
early which is also revolutionary kind
of a publication so his career is this
arc really from the Rockets a newspaper
days in San Francisco through the the
the high points of the New Journalism I
would recommend that you all find or
look up Lewis's piece about being with
the Beatles in the 60s when the Beatles
were seeking not redemption are they
seeking enlightenment with the Maharishi
now Louis has a point of view about that
if you read this book you'll enjoy that
all the way through to the digital evils
that we have going on now which he is
surfing like like the ho daddy that he
is and it's a wonderful wonderful book I
I just I think what I'd like to do is
start with the first paragraph of the
book Louis in which you suggest that
after you have to go before you buy the
book or TT going to make you buy the
book read that first paragraph in the
book on your way out and you'll be sold
anyway them in the the heart of the
paragraph you suggest that Donald Trump
is not a surprise really that's true
that's that's the point I mean Donald
Trump who's been walking down the road
toward his nomination for the presidency
of the United States from the Year 2016
according to them it's the way it's been
going for for 25 years and family the
book is a series of essays that were
written over the course of the 25 years
from 1990 2015 setting up the premise of
that generalization
so you have in 1991 you have George
President George HW Bush staging the or
sending the gunboats to Iran and the
Louis the second Gulf War sending the
gunboats and the cameras to display with
self congratulatory explosives the great
making America great again that was what
he was essentially attempting to do the
United States was caught or the
Washington Consensus was caught off
guard by the coming down of the Berlin
Wall in 1989 and the implosion of the
evil Soviet empire this was something
that had never been predicted either by
the thinkers in the Pentagon or the
thinkers writing for the New York Review
of Books what let me interrupt you is
that yes that's the point in time and
you're thinking but here comes Trump I'm
thinking here comes Trump because what
it is is self-congratulatory
explosions in the in the Persian Gulf of
1991 really to simply advertise the
greatness of the great American Empire
and what you've got with Trump is
self-congratulatory
bursts of bombast bursting in air I mean
it's the same kind of it's the same kind
of see that's a network there that's the
thing I know about self-promotion I mean
and then they ax and Trump is in he's in
the news and in 1989 I mean he's opened
his Trump Tower but why do you why do
you think the Republicans didn't see
this coming like
the murder of publicans got caught up in
a dream of glory of the dream of
American Empire the dream that of that
there was nobody else in the world that
mattered except the United States the
American Way was the right way and that
any impertinent nation that had the
refused to see it it was it would it was
our obligation to destroy those people I
mean that's the what was called the
National Defense strategy for the 1990s
published in 1993 written by Dick Cheney
and Paul Wolfowitz and it sets out very
clearly the doctrines of preemptive
strike and forward deterrence commits
the United States to maintain two major
wars on two continents at any one time
and to take out any any country that any
nation any failed state that doesn't
wish to accept the American guidance
guidance guides and it was also the same
year if you got to remember that god
what's the guy's name the guy that wrote
the book the end of history the great
guru did you know I mean yeah Fukuyama
Fukuyama is talking about the end of
history same here in 1989-1990
that the american way is the only way
it's established the world of you know
that the competition of ideas is over
Soviet Union is collapsed and the only
thing left to do is is maintenance of
the perfection of the American idea you
also write in the book that we've lost
our grasp of the American tradition of
revolutionary thinking a revolutionary
theory if you call it I mean yes
contradictory to me Terry I mean the
thing that's startling is you know when
I began putting these essays together
starting in 1991 and bringing it forward
to 2016 is how little the thinking has
changed I mean we talked about era of
spectacular change technology Silicon
Valley robots I mean and so forth but
the thinking in Washington the so-called
Washington Consensus has not changed at
all well you also say that that our
history is a resource because you are at
a store Ian you say it's a great
resource and that we are squandering it
we are I mean that's the reason that I
left harper's magazine in 2006 7 in
order to start the Lavin's quarterly
which is a deal which is about history
and I think that of history as an
immensely generative source of hope
energy and ideas also irony as a reader
of the Lapham yeah well I orderly other
words I think why are any irony is
simply the lessons of experience Terry
that's all ah irony is not a the lessons
of experience yes yeah well but no I
think history is enormous ly valuable
you want to say at one point in the book
that the that our our satirist are not
playing with fire the way they should be
playing with fire well they're not
laying yourself there no they're not
playing with fire in the same way that
well actually I'm borrowing that idea
from Mark Twain but Twain looked at
satire as a form of arson
to burn down the hospitality tents of
self-congratulatory can't it was running
you guys get that sentence yes
burn down the self-congratulatory tality
hospitality tentative
self-congratulatory
can't that's pretty much quote all need
this book you know I'm riffing on Twain
there well I mean he thought satire as
the crime of arson and that was what it
was intended to do and he was an adult
and when as he turned more he had began
to have more edge as he got older he
didn't publish some of his most acerbic
commentary because it would hurt his you
know public persona as as the friendly
garrulous man in the white suit right so
it wasn't a lot of it wasn't published
until after his death and then only over
the strenuous objections of his
daughters who were afraid that the
posthumous publication of Twain's most
biting satire would destroy his
reputation but the but then it's oh no I
don't want anybody off the hook I mean
and the thing is with with our conscious
cetera or the kind of satire has become
you know Saturday Night Live and John
Stewart and so on they let us off the
hook because they say it's all a joke
we're all in the know okay we've got
crooks running the big uh vermin not
only crooks but unbelievably stupid
incompetence I mean our our military it
is is a
disaster I mean we present our military
I mean the media the big media presents
it as the most powerful force in the
world a child Krauthammer in the year
2000 2001 four months before the attack
on the Trade Towers and Time magazine
says America is the most powerful
military the most powerful nation since
since Imperial Rome the world will be
bent to our will I mean I'm quoting but
this was the auntie this is the
consensus of opinion in Washington now
the point is our military and we start
off with the invasion at Iraq again in
1993 expecting a walk in the park
expecting to transform the whole the
Middle East into Connecticut and the to
do this with the most magnificent
military force ever assembled in the
history of the world I mean this is
every editorial in The New York Times
this was new bait you know this is
Network News television and so on the
truth is the United States hadn't won a
war in well hadn't fought a war in 45
years had won awards 70 years I mean our
American military essentially is is show
business as an advertisement we do we
make more movies what yeah you watch
television not very often
well I mean how do you get how do you
get how are you inform if you're not
watching like a vvz the campaign
coverage on television you are you're
not watching some of that I've watched
some of it you don't have to see a lot
of it I mean you get the idea
risen really quite early I mean it's the
you know I saw a trump come down the you
know the deus ex machina in June 2015
when he comes down the escalator in the
atrium of the Trump Tower and announces
himself as candidate for the United
States okay
I mean for the next for the presidency
that was his announcement
okay now that guess you asked me how
things have been coming at us for the
last 25 years in Trump's no surprise
okay if you saw that which I did on on
television it's almost exactly george w
bush on the deck of the united states
carrier USS Abraham Lincoln May 1st 2004
sorry 2003 me saying mission
accomplished right it's the same kind of
deus ex machina appearance I mean he
comes out of a fighter jet wearing a
costume that in you know Top Gun costume
Swagger's up to the microphone and says
mission is accomplished we had already
lost the war in terror on three months
after we started it the war had begun in
March of 2003 with a magnificent air
show over Baghdad
this is disrupt more munitions on it but
this sounds like a Saturday Night Live
skit Louis it's not as very good but I'm
pointing it out because I think that
that kind of that kind of satire is
effective on television yes but they
save the trouble with the television is
they save that kind of satire until two
years later nobody was saying that you
know the guy in the media in 2003 the
media was comparing
Bush and the United States Army in two -
you know the Americans at d-day they
were comparing the American generals -
to normal
I mean the I mean the hype god I mean
but what's the guy's name at CNN he was
he was going to put I mean Wolf Blitzer
no no no they you know the guy that was
going to carry a gun and go personally
the Tora Bora and gunned down bin Laden
right I don't do you anyone know what
y'all do Geraldo they never let him on
that Peralta
listen let's stop for a minute you know
there any questions will come we'll come
back if you find it questions in the
middle sometime shake things up anybody
have any questions both fat yes thank
you people that by the only problem I
have with this analysis is that it's
very easy to be wise after the event I'm
sorry
the only problem I have the dis analysis
that it's very easy to be wise after
there no but the point of the book is it
with on the event user essays that are
printed exactly as it happens right I'm
not writing this 25 years later I am
writing it then no no I appreciate that
that's just sort of in terms in terms of
how all of this what plays into trunk I
mean the thing is that you know in the
years and months and years after the
infamous carrier incident that sort of
Display of power came to be ridiculed
right it's not necessarily a linear
narrative that we go from there
no no misunderstanding it it I'm not
following
Trump for 25 years I'm following the
self congratulatory attitude of the
American so-called Washington Consensus
of the
of the Republican Party of the the
neoconservative sense of American Empire
I mean the notion of American group
great again the notion of American can
do anything at god damn well pleases in
the world that the trumpian arrogance
and actually stupidity has been
characteristic of the way that we have
been managing our government and foreign
policy and military for for 25 years
that's all I'm saying I'm not no I'm I'm
not following Trump I mean I met Trump
in it 1989 and once wasn't enough have
the job you know I'm talking about the
cipa sensibility not not the and the
sensibility was pervasive I mean it was
a systematic and it's in the second
paragraph in the book I I go back to
Aristotle and Aristotle is talking about
this the way forms of government follow
one another democracy monarchy despotism
and so on right it's a circle and what
he says is that all governments all
governments start off as oligarchies a
relatively a relative few people with
the money in the society attempt to set
up a government
it's what the founders of the United
States were setting up trying to set up
in Washington and sorry Philadelphia in
1787 Madison says that Madison says we
are trying to establish a government
that will be run by people with the
wisdom to discern and the virtue to
pursue the common good of the society
that's a direct quote the people who
signed the Constitution are all rich
they're the merchants rich from the
Northeast and the plantation rich from
the south and they are undertaking to
provide a government a constitution that
will allow balance the the a democratic
society with a capitalist consumer
economy and those two things are very
different a democracy democratic society
values equality
it's the motions of the heart the
capitalist economy has no interest in
equality none it's about more for me and
less for you and goodbye and good luck
that's Trump bluest what you are is that
what you mean by what you call the
deliberate imprecision of the
Constitution yes they're trying to set
up that balance they're kind of balanced
emotions of the heart with the movements
of a market so how very successful and
they do that but the trouble with that
is it takes a continued paying of
attention on the part of the of the
people who are managing that form of
government they were trying to set up a
with a republic and republics last only
as long as the people that are engaged
in it really work at it and the and pay
attention but that doesn't happen sooner
or later and on our stuff this is
Aristotle again
not me Serizawa it's also Madison sooner
or later all lagares turn rancid they
get that they're like cheese they go bad
in the Sun because as wealth accumulates
the men's decay that is you can see that
all the weight that happens all I mean
that happens in Greece that happens in
Rome that happens and and he has osteon
regime in France and it happens in the
United States people think the Greeks
called it the disease was called Cleo
leak Co
which is the disease that imagines that
there is nothing that money can't buy
and it plan Ixia is the desire for more
more of everything we're dancing girls
more cruise missiles more floors on the
buildings on 57th Street more
circulation more more of everything and
the Greeks call that pouillon Ixia and
they call that the disease that the the
idea that there is nothing that money
can't buy and the United States falls
into that disease in spades I mean I
mean the I mean of course the couple of
hundred years of Americans existence I
mean there have been many struggles with
that that's the struggle if it's a
Jackson has with the banks in the 1830s
that's the struggle of the progressive
populist parties rising at the end of
the 19th century that's you know the
country crucified on the cross of gold
that's William Jennings Bryan that's
part of the of what's in Teddy
Roosevelt's mind when he is picking the
argument with the trust it's the same
thing that's in the mind of
of Franklin D Roosevelt isn't when he's
putting together the the New Deal I mean
this is a constant struggle Lewis writes
in the book that is a quote the
foretelling of the apocalypse never
loses its appeal as we have just heard
from Lewis no it never appeals to loses
its appeal I mean they Reacher's in
Puritan Massachusetts would get up and
when they were speaking from the pulpit
they would actually they've learned to
cry like you know actors at wiping the
tears from their eyes because of the
sins of the world that had been visited
upon the congregation in Cambridge and
the world was coming to an Jonathan
Edwards sinners in the hands of an angry
god
but the priests would actually I mean
sorry preachers what it would actually
learn to weep tears I mean you know they
like the columns of David Brooks I mean
it's it's the Lea it's yeah I say the
column David Broder or Brooke Brooks I
mean if that's what I did wear it well
know that what the whole the idea this
the world is going to hell I mean you
know I mean well is it though no good
news I was going into anymore hell and
it's been through many many times before
you have no idea how reassuring that
instrument it should be I mean yeah well
no that's one of the great values of
history no but here we are on the brink
of the election of what right yeah the
two most unpopular candidates right in
history of the Republic right well I
just stop there and actually what you
make of that
well we they're black a popular that
with whatever
that is well it it might persuade enough
people in the country look like those in
this room the people essentially who own
the country under to pay attention to
politics I mean for the last 30 odd
years I mean people who have a stake in
the country who own you know people who
run the banks and so forth and so on
people that enjoy the privileges of
American citizenship have had almost no
interest in politics they've been
perfectly happy to leave it to the hired
help
who cares who wants to go to why I mean
as you and I both know Terry and there
are a lot of very talented interesting
intelligent thoughtful courageous people
in the United States but they don't go
into politics what was in your
background that kept you from entering
the arena Japanese from entering the
arena no I'm just saying there's got to
be some horrible skeleton that would
they would have come over come out and
senator no no that I actually
entertained the thought at one point but
very briefly I mean I attend well tell
us about that well as you know my
grandfather was the mayor of San
Francisco during World War two and I
often accompanied him on his rounds as
mayor and I also as the mayor of San
Francisco in 1945 he was obliged to
preside over the formation of the
charter of the United Nations which how
old were you loose
ten and so he excuse me from school and
I had to go to the plenary sessions of
the formation of the UN in 1945 also
during the course of the war the the
mayor would be obliged to go out in a
launch and means the returning carriers
coming in from the war in the Pacific so
at the age of nine I was being piped
aboard the enterprise and introduced to
Admiral Nimitz or Admiral Halsey and
that makes a very big impression on a
nine-year-old did you have a little
short pants on yeah yeah top that okay
beside that grandfather was it was a
very unconventional politician he'd been
a ship owner during the 30s we had a we
had a family at a shipping company and
the times he ran for mayor on the ground
that he would serve one term and one
term only and that he would make all the
decisions to do with what he thought
ought to be done and what was right
twice during his four-year term the
Machine politicians tried to impeach him
because he really did a lot of damage to
the - to the Machine politics in the
city and both times he was restored with
with a higher majority and the he was a
very popular mayor Banny and he did he
try to stay absolutely fixed on his
civic purpose on the end at the end they
said to him well Jesus yeah I mean you
could run for governor and he said no I
made one deal and that's it so I had
that kind of an idea and and the so I
thought okay I'd start out in the
newspaper business in San Francisco and
learned something and about politics and
then I would come to New York and I
would learn something about journalism
and worked for a big-time newspaper and
meet people like you Terry
but then I would go back to California
and and had possibly you know attempt to
get elected senator actually had that
idea right but then I well then well a
lot of different things happen but but
to you one of them was I was married to
a woman who had absolutely no interest
or willingness to you know play the part
of it the part of a wife of a politician
is horrible on the she said I wouldn't
put it through it so what Luis did
instead was stayed in the East Coast and
began to mock the West Coast muck mock I
know this because I was reading all this
time did you not I wrote one well guess
I because it would because this is such
a good place to live as a person of
letters and ideas that was that was your
point no no my point was that austra I
don't think now the part of the point
came out of my experience of the San
Francisco Examiner
I'm on the San Francisco Examiner in 19
let's see it's my laughter so it's 1959
and there was a mistake the examiners
are Hearst paper but there was also a
los angeles examiner also a Hearst paper
and there's Sunday word of reviewer
sections magazine sections in those days
were both published printed in
Bakersfield
Ronald Revere was a toys an old
publishing a printing of technology that
required you to print six weeks
was it not before the deadline yeah it
was what you were wave oh yeah right
well it was newsprint it wasn't glossy
like New York Times Magazine and the so
but they mixed it up they put the story
at 12
it was intended to be in the Los Angeles
accident paper they'd put the cover of
the San Francisco paper on it so Sunday
morning comes in San Francisco papers
you know we have the paper and it says
Los Angeles it's a San Francisco
Examiner Los Angeles the Athens of the
West and in San Francisco is a very
self-satisfied town how was it if your
fault Louis not my fault not my fault
which you were blamed for you've told me
no I was playing I'll tell you why I was
blamed for it because I so we have this
horrible thing we have Los Angeles the
Athens of the West and then there 12
pages photographs bela bartok is still
alive
thomas mom christopher isherwood igor
stravinsky Morris Lewis Raymond Chandler
long list all in la-la brat back at the
time I guess it was a pretty big time
prospect
the the and I came I was a young
reporter so I was the first person in on
at ten o'clock on Monday morning on
Sunday morning and all the brats the
paper was there the managing editor the
publisher son and they had gathered
around the copy table and they were
looking at this thing and it was an
attitude of I thought a cruise ship had
sunk and and a thousand were dead in the
bay I mean it had that kind of crisis
and they brought me over and they said
this is heresy San Francisco is the
Athens of the West everybody knows right
and and you will write for tomorrow's
paper the Monday paper banner headline
no no San Francisco is the Athens okay
and I I'm given it's 10:30 in the
morning and I have the deadlines for you
have to noon and I have to back up that
headline right and it couldn't be none I
mean Henry Miller was in Big Sur
okay the Evan canal was in Sausalito
that was the ballgame doing nobody in
San Francisco the Opera was Roadshow
theater was Roadshow New York there was
no serious music there was some jazz but
that was the modern jazz quartet but but
they were they weren't wounded in San
Francisco narration had left by that
time the he so I mean I came to the
managing editor at four o'clock and I
said I for one sir do not believe that
there was an Athens of the West but if
there is it is in Los Angeles
I was fired you had Twitter to your
class
you know your grandfather was mayor you
know and so on have Andrea and so they
assigned the story to imprisoned
journalists 35 years old mortgage three
children no choice to write the story
and he wrote it and he simply attributed
to it it quotes from Lois Laurie owner
of a flashy restaurant of course San
Francisco is the Athens of the web
second quote from Cyril magnin owner of
magnums department store no question
San Francisco is the African West third
quote was from Hurricane Baghdad by the
bag I was going to throw that in I
wasn't in favorite network that was
you're not he's a quarterback Corey is
either O'Kane I mean that you know that
and that to me it basically is the what
that is the way the media works yourself
being set but that's this that's what
the you know
our national news media is setup to to
show that our armies are invincible and
and and so on right to paint the paint a
rosy picture on the on the you know me
it's an advertisement for reality
whether that's the status quo I mean in
that but that's natural that's what the
media is supposed to do we just round
this up by asking me what you're going
to do an election night what what are
you gonna do an election night I'm
assuming you know I'm going to watch it
with quietly at at home with my wife
down the you got to vote and like I vote
no I'm not going to vote my vote does
not count Perry please let's not go
through that deep it's in the book Louis
it's in the book yeah I love your
numbers exact that maybe the people who
don't vote have good and sufficient
reasons for their abstentions also in
New York in the city of New York I mean
if the electoral college is Democratic I
mean the reason that the politicians
don't bother to come and talk to anybody
in New York is because it's at that you
know doesn't matter who I vote for it
will be the New York State is democratic
they're only whatever they are six swing
states in the whole United States where
the vote actually made count so we we
should drive to North Carolina and buy
ourselves some what letter rallies
no I'm kidding you let's go to some
questions yeah um Thank You Lewis for
the talk Mike my question goes back to
your statement about history being
important yeah and as Eisenhower said
warned us of the military and
real complex and when Jack Kennedy was
in the White House he was trying to
negotiate with the Russians to calm down
the Cold War and the military
it seems to me wanted to ramp up in
Vietnam and approximately 48 hours after
Jack Kennedy was killed Johnson put an
order through to put the troops into
Vietnam and I'm wondering if the
business of America isn't really the
business of war and the war machine and
it started there and as Jim Garrison
said if this crime is not properly
investigated the Republic will not hold
your thoughts well I think that's
largely true I mean I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but with the the bone and
marrow of the American economy
is the military-industrial complex and
that and Eisenhower was right about that
and the that is what you know sustained
the American economy through the second
half of the last century and the that is
the reason in 1991 you know now comes
the Cold War the Russians comes down the
khole you know the Soviet Union
collapses Berlin Wall comes down and
this is why it's such a major event in
Washington because they've been using
the Cold War
did bills and constantly build up the
military-industrial complex right and
you know how that works I mean they got
contracts in every state and so on in
the independent it's not just a military
budget it's also the contractors it's
also the corporation's it's the the
arsenal of freedom right I mean the I
don't know what it is today but General
Electric one of the greatest arms
manufacturers in the country owns NBC I
mean I don't know if they still do what
they did but essentially they own them
the same people are on the media and the
so so yes time to you know I feel like
I'm on top radio with Danny yeah nobody
I mean but a lot of people have said
this this is not this is not a radical
point of view I mean Oliver Stone wrote
the whole book along that line but so
did John Appleton Williams in the 60s I
mean so did a guy who I can't remember
his name but the general the world war
is a racket in the in the 20s and 30s it
was an American Colonel who was running
our Wars and in you know a United Fruit
Company in in Guatemala Honduras and
then indeed yes I mean and our wars have
been elective I mean we were attacked in
in World War two but all the other
American wars had been our choice
Mexican War like war against the Indians
and in the in the 19th century
spanish-american war
Korean War Vietnam war our choice and
the yes I mean so the
and there is a very fine book actually
that that's a again other people have
said this I'm not a talk show you know
radical but it's a very fine book that
was published last spring by guy named
Andrew bacevich was called America's war
for the greater Middle East and he tells
the story of our picking that fight in
nineteen eighty Jimmy Carter desert one
if you remember the helicopter that had
come to rescue Iranian I mean what I
also have and that book is marvelous and
goes into very very specific detail I
also had a guy Godfather I mean again
it's another point of reference Linda my
godfather was a man named torque L River
he was a very good friend of my
grandfather and river was in norwegia
and he'd run away to see even my family
was in the Texas oil business
Texaco not Standard Oil and the reverb
became the first tanker captain of the
first in Texas tanker 1910 sailing out
of Brownsville Texas and by 1930 he was
chairman of the board of Mexico on the
Texaco was as what a lot of other
American companies you know I'm dealing
with the Germans all the way through the
30s and the Texaco Texas oil was
supplying fuel to the
german condor squadrons there were at
work in spain and and the by 1953 river
was the you know the grand old manatee
of the american oil business he'd been
part of the people that had set up a
Ramco in in saudi arabia in 50s on the
and the americans were having trouble
with Mossadegh in around ryan
democratically elected president of that
country but that but he was threatening
to take the oil business nationalize the
oil take it back from the from the from
the british you mean it had been Anglo
british american oil
I mean British British oil and River was
called down to Washington and told to go
to bring matza Decca message and the
message was mr. Massad ik you either
give us the oil or we kill that simple
so your answer is yes I mean it there's
a lot of you know I don't got it with
you there are a lot of people that have
written books on various angles of this
but yes America is a war making country
and we have been for a long time take
another quick question 11 you highlight
still haven't you highlight the
arrogance and stupidity the
neo-conservatives
arrogance and stupidity particularly
embodied in Donald Trump but what are
your thoughts on the arrogance and
stupidity the neoliberal arrogance house
of saying I mean it mean I don't make
that much of a
I don't make that much of a distinction
between neoliberal and neoconservatives
in the and if you read the book I mean
you will see that you know it goes
across 25 years and I have just as many
observations of the Clinton and the neo
liberals as I do of the bush and the
neoconservative I mean I mean as far as
I know the Hillary Clinton seems to be
part of the Washington Consensus with
which has been there for a long time and
it's nonpartisan can I can I quote this
out with a remark of my own who have any
more questions yes I had a question more
so why you're not out you're studying
out of conspiracy theorists I'm sorry
you said you're not a conspiracy
theorist but Donald Trump certainly
seems to be and I feel like what he has
brought about more so for me that's
concerning is uh him questioning the
rigging of the elections every time
someone brings up a fact he comes up
with something else that's maybe not
backed up and that's something that I
don't know if it's internet culture or
if that's the future of you know because
everyone has their own echo chamber and
I feel like that is what I'm most
concerned about uh going forward for
future politicians I really didn't
understand that question I feel like I
had a hard time hearing you because of
the way the microphone was are you
asking me what what do I think is
happening next I don't know right I'm
going to don't use the microphone the
reverb is what it's jumbling it just the
democratization of facts and conspiracy
theories
the Internet is bad for democracy yes I
mean it makes it very hard to democracy
is about about people face to face right
and the trouble with the in the kind of
argument you could have in this inner
illness sighs right Madison again talks
about democracy it hasn't necessarily be
small and it has to be small enough so
that the various people within it of
different walks of balance ages and so
on I mean this is Thomas Paine's idea of
democracy and it was maybe possible in
the United States in 1800 or 3 million
people in the United States that women
don't have the vote blacks don't have
the vote people without sufficient
property don't have the vote and the
people that are the small oligarchy that
Madison was talking about they can talk
to each other right with the internet
people are departing from one another
literally at Lightspeed I mean that you
know they can live in their own little
world they don't have to hear anybody
that disagrees with them they don't have
to try to compromise you know they don't
have to here they are and they're in
their own self confirming universe right
and democracy is about friction it's
about change its about argument it's
it's it's it's not a safe place it's a
very hard thing
and it depends on friction even as
democracy depends upon the free flow of
information yeah yeah okay okay here's
my sentiment the trouble the Internet it
drives people into you know many many
different little worlds of their own and
then it's hard to you know get that
moving in one direction here's my story
and with this Louis is a great great
golfer he doesn't brag about this being
very very fine scratch golfer has been
for years and years place quite often
when I was at Sports Illustrated
I met Donald Trump because of his
interest in golf and golf courses and
Donald Trump cheats at golf the other
you know the other politician who's
famous for cheating at golf is Bill
Clinton this little bit of information I
impart to you similarly underline the
fact that Lewis's book has that kind of
fun with conservatives liberals radicals
or whatever it arches over the whole
thing to point out really who's cheating
that's a great book should we thank mr.
Lapham
[Applause]
thank you everybody we're going to real
quick move the speakers up to the front
for signing so if everybody could give
us maybe ten seconds to get moved before
you all get out so be appreciated
thank you